قال رالف والدو إيمرسون ذات مرة أن
الموتى لا يمكن تحقيق أي شيء عظيم
بدون الحماس.
كانت القطارات تحتوي على قطارات حول شجرة الكريسماس
عندما كنت طفلاً
أينما كنت أخطط لخطط Trek
وبعد ذلك على مدار 18 عامًا أضفت خمسة
أقبية إلى المنزل ومن ثم أصبحت
جيدًا إلى حد ما في صنع الجبال
والجسور وأعمال التصميم
وقررنا  أعطيها للعالم ، لذلك قمنا بتمزيقها
بالكامل ، اشترينا هذه الأرض المبنية من
Northlands في أي يوم من الأيام ، نقوم بتشغيل ما بين
85 و 90 قطارًا بعض التفاصيل في
Northlands داخل حوالي 40.000 قدم من
المسار حوالي 4000 مبنى على 400
جسر العديد من الجبال هنا
يبلغ ارتفاعها ثلاثة طوابق ونصف ، ومعظم
الأشياء هنا عبارة عن خدش مبني
أسفل البنية الفوقية بأكملها ،
وهناك ما يكفي من الخشب لبناء حوالي 42
منزلًا كبيرًا  قبل بضع ساعات
حتى يتمكن الشخص العادي من رؤية
كل شيء نريده الملايين من الديون
لبناء هذا المكان في كل مكان اعتقدت فيه
أننا مكسرات ، الشخص الوحيد الذي اعتقد
أن ما أريد فعله هو زوجتي
وكانت معي تمامًا  هذه المرة الكبيرة ،
إنها محاولة فنية ، إنها
هدية للعالم بما يمكنني فعله
وتجعل الكثير من الناس يسعدونك